peut-être alors on a besoin vial qui est
avec nous rescapés du bataclan auteur du
livre fragments poste donc je ne sais
pas j'ai pas votre liban ne l'a pas
donnée on l'a pas emmené donc on va
comptable l'année excusez-nous benjamin
alors benjamin vous vous étiez au
bataclan
vous étiez avec qui j'étais avec mon
épouse
ouais on se trouvait vers le fond de la
salle c'est à dire près de l'entrée où
il y avait le stand de t-shirts pas loin
juste à côté d'eux j'étais près du bar
du bar voilà avec votre femme oui et à
quel moment vous êtes rendu compte qu'il
s'agissait d'une attaque terroriste
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a entendu
assez on a on entendu effectivement ces
bruits de tirs que beaucoup ont
identifié à des pétards au départ et moi
je me suis retourné j'ai vu des gens qui
rentraient en courant donc les gens qui
ont été parce qu'apparemment ils ont
tiré ils ont commencé à tirer à
l'extérieur donc il ya des gens qui sont
rentrés en courant dans la salle donc
moins voyant ces gens rentrés en courant
j'ai compris que vous les avez envie de
dire vous attaquez nos frères en syrie
alors mis en doute pas de suite pas tout
de suite mais moi j'ai compris et j'ai
compris tout de suite qu'il y avait des
tirs je pense que c'est ce qui m'a sauvé
parce que moi j'ai plongé tout de suite
au sol
j'ai eu cette chance là parce que je
sais que là où je me trouvais il je
pense qu'il reste
il est pas rester grand monde qui a pas
été touché
alors vous avez vous êtes jetés au sol
tout de suite alors votre femme n'était
pas avec vous elles sont éloignées en
entendant les premiers bruits qu'est ce
qui s'est passé ensuite
alors donc effectivement j'étais au sol
face contre terre je voyais rien du tout
j'entendais des bruits
j'avais perdu ma femme de vue
effectivement et puis j'avais
décor autour de moi ce surmoi en dessous
gt gt effectivement attendez votre tour
vous dites oui c'est ça je en fait
j'aime je ne voyais pas d'issue je me
suis pas vu mort mais je me suis dit je
vois là ça va arriver
alors vous étiez totalement impuissant
bien entendu vous entier des bals des
impacts de balles sur le corps au dessus
de vous ouais vous sentiez le sang des
autres coulées sur vos pieds c'est un
vrai j'avais des morceaux de cervelle
survol sur les lunettes vous dit
j'étais rempli de sang et de chair
humaine et comment au moment où vous
êtes relevé alors moi effectivement je
me suis relevé qu'en ce commissaire et
est entré dont on parlait tout à l'heure
et qu'il a effectivement j'ai compris
plus tard tout ça on comprend pas sur le
moment mais il a effectivement abattu ce
le théorise qui était sur la scène et il
a dit sortez sortez et voilà moi je ne
me suis pas ça aurait pu être un
terroriste il disait ça il y avait une
chance sur votre chemin
voilà j'ai je suis sorti comme j'ai pu
j'ai retrouvé ma femme qui était là qui
avait rien eu il y avait eu un petit
éclat de balle mais rien de ces fous ça
faisait de la chambre phase on a eu tous
les deux énormément de chance et on est
sortis par l'entrée principale est
étonnamment il n'y a pas beaucoup de
gens qu'ils ont sorti en même temps que
nous donc qu'est ce que vous considérez
comme un miraculé où vous êtes
complètement oui mais j'ai beaucoup j'ai
eu beaucoup de chance
ouais vous juste comment peut- être que
c'est la question que nori debré comment
on vit à prayssas qu'on est toujours est
ce que vous êtes traumatisés quand vous
sortez ne reste que vous êtes arrivé à
sortir dès le lendemain de chez vous
bien
alors moi ma reconstruction s'est passé
par étapes
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de raconter
dans ce livre en fait un petit peu enfin
je pense comme grégory aussi le j'ai
senti qu'il y avait quelque chose qu'il
fallait écrire parce que je le vivais
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire
entre guillemets on va dire parce que
c'était vraiment quelque chose qu'on
connaît pas que moi je évidemment je
connaissais pas que dont j'avais jamais
entendu parler
et je me suis dit il faut il faut que
j'écrive ce qu'il m'arrive parce que on
perd très vite le les pédales on perd
très vite le contrôle de tout ce qu'on
ressent et bien sûr et voilà donc il y
avait des moments de panique des
hallucinations des sait des choses on à
moi j'avais besoin de l'écrire pour que
ça vous a fait du bien oui oui tout à
fait un nom et agathe et vous raconter
effet bien fort a raconté pardon
effectivement très bien c'est cet après
qui est différent pour chacune des
victimes des survivants vous racontez ça
a été d'ailleurs différents pour vous et
votre famille cette reconstruction cette
survie comme vous l'appelez vous parlez
vous évoquez des phobies qui nous n'avez
pas être qu'ils n'étaient pas à l'avant
des réactions complètement bizarre même
que vous même ne compreniez pas et vous
vous livrez quand même un message
d'espoir à la fin de ce livre en nous
expliquant vous avez pu retourner à des
concerts même à des festivals et alors
vous avez carrément du mal à juste
sortir de chez vous êtes dans l'espace
public vous mouvoir dans cet espace
public sans avoir peur d'eux est donc
trois ans après aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qui vous en reste
est-ce que alors moi moi je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui je revis normalement
normalement maintenant j'ai plus ces
faux billets récurrents toutes ces
images ou alors je peux être mal à
l'aise
dans le métro par exemple donc j'évite
de prendre le métro
bon mais j'ai vite c'est tout c'est
juste et je mens et je vais voter mais
pour prolonger la question d'agde vous
raconter quelque chose auquel on pense
pas c'est que quand on a vécu quelque
chose comme ça tout ce qui se rapporte
au terrorisme le réveil dans un premier
temps et le terroriste dans votre liste
c'est presque le fond d'écran de votre
reer apparemment vous avez réussi à
passer ça mais le moindre événement qui
se rapporte aux terroristes que ça soit
un attentat proprement dit dans le monde
entier l'information dans le monde
entier ça réveille le trauma traduit un
combien de temps la phrase vraiment et
guillou la phase aiguë ça a peut-être
durer quatre mois ont pour moi j'ai
comme et comme disent agathe
effectivement tout le monde se
reconstruit ou tentent de reconstruire
de se reconstruire différemment
moi j'ai eu je vais dire la chance de
trouver la solution pour moi mais
évidemment c'est c'est pas une solution
unique et universel et vous avez gardé
fraude rock and roll
cette fois vous avez gardé foi dans le
rock n roll ou de tresses na waie